hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español la madre de plaza
de mayo conmemorar un 45 años de lucha
el 30 de abril de 1977 por primera vez
un grupo de mujeres se reunió en la
ciudad de buenos aires para reclamar por
la aparición de sus hijos secuestrados
por la última dictadura cívico-militar
argentina tras golpear puertas en
solitario se hicieron finalmente caminar
juntas en la plaza de mayo frente a la
casa de gobierno ellos querían saber
dónde estaban sus hijos y nadie les
decía la respuesta cuarenta y cinco años
después de su primera ronda son todo un
símbolo mundial de resistencia y de
lucha saludamos y agradecemos muchísimo
su presencia en transmití cuatro a nora
cortiñas cofundadora de madres de plaza
de mayo y de madres de plaza de
mayo-línea fundadora nora muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en esta
entrevista
bueno muchas gracias a ustedes por tener
memoria por acompañarnos en esta
búsqueda de verdad de justicia
y gracias a la memoria que tenemos
alrededor del mundo y nos ayuda a que
estén presentes nuestros 30.000
detenidos y detenidos desaparecidos no
gracias a ustedes no era una vez más no
era usted dijo en alguna oportunidad que
después de aquella primera ronda no
volvieron a ser las mismas que balance
hace de estos 45 años
no efectivamente la vida nos cambio
cambio la familia la falta de gustado
hasta el día de hoy se siente seguimos
en esta lucha seguimos esperando que se
abran los archivos y que nos digan qué
pasó con todas y todos los detenidos
desaparecidos también queremos que los
bebés que fueron apropiados de sus
madres cautivas en los campos de
concentración
esos jóvenes que disney fueron
entregados a familias desconocidas que
hoy recuperen su identidad también
buscamos esa noticia tan importante
declaramos en la audiencia porque usted
mencionaba a gustavo gustavo es su hijo
quien fuera detenido y desaparecido por
la última dictadura militar argentina
para que deudas hay en la democracia que
reparaciones hacen falta por parte del
estado
nosotros la reparación y la justicia
sería la única y lo importante
reparación era que nos pudiéramos haber
reencontrado con nuestros hijos con
nuestras hijas como sabemos que ellos no
están con vida por todas las evidencias
que tuvimos por todas las
investigaciones que se hicieron sabemos
que lo que necesitamos es que haya
justicia para que nunca más se repitan
estos hechos tan aberrantes como que es
para la represión usar la desaparición
forzada de personas es el crimen de
crímenes
absolutamente se vuelve a saber qué pasó
con ellos y ellas y ellos los que han
estado secuestrados pierden todo
contacto con su familia y ya no sabemos
cómo fue su final siquiera
no era las semillas de búsqueda de
memoria de verdad y de justicia no como
usted bien decía ya han quedado
plantadas en la república argentina
también a lo largo de todo el mundo y
han crecido se han multiplicado ahora en
algún momento la lucha deberá continuar
sin la presencia física de las madres
por supuesto es que han sido y están
acompañadas por muchísimas personas que
trabajan con ustedes también tienen gran
el apoyo de gran parte del pueblo
argentino un apoyo incondicional no
obstante sienten confianza en que su
lucha continuará y en buenas manos
además
desde luego la lucha continuará con los
otros hijos con los hermanos con los
nietos y con los bisnietos la lucha siga
en el pueblo porque la desaparición
forzada y el crimen que se cometió no
termina así porque se sigue repitiendo
en otros países del mundo también en
estos momentos así que en la lucha
nuestra es para el futuro para el
presente y para el futuro para este que
no haya impunidad que no quede ningún
este genocida libre que puedan volver a
cometer esas aberraciones que se
cometieron que hasta fueron torturados
niños fueron torturadas mujeres
embarazadas se llevaron también a las
madres que buscaban a sus hijos todos
los crímenes aberrantes que se
cometieron no pueden quedar impunes de
ninguna manera
ahora no era su activismo se expandió
hacia nuevas causas no que son más
características de este siglo por
ejemplo de la defensa de la igualdad de
género no en este sentido por ejemplo
palabras como feminismo patriarcado no
estaban en el lenguaje como uno ni en
las agendas en la década del 70 en
aquellos tiempos cuando comenzaban con
su activismo y con su lucha no obstante
en los últimos años no le hemos visto a
usted misma con el pañuelo verde
acompañada de muchísimas jóvenes cómo ha
sido esa vinculación con otras
militancia con otros movimientos de
mujeres
bueno primero nosotros recogimos las
banderas de lucha de nuestros hijos de
nuestras hijas y se luchaba para un
bienestar para el pueblo se duchaba para
vivir una vida digna y nosotras las
madres recogimos esas banderas de lucha
vamos hasta veces acompañadas juntamente
por este los jóvenes de esa generación
que quedaron con vida y que nos
acompañan más otras dos generaciones más
de jóvenes que fueron creciendo y que
bueno ahora son los nietos y los
bisnietos
realmente no pagamos y además abarcamos
muchas este
temas que hacen a la actualidad como las
madres ahora estamos en una lucha muy
dura
-este por la injusticia social porque
nos quieren hacer pagar una deuda
externa que no debemos porque hay y
provincias en argentina que no tienen
agua que viven en situaciones muy
inferiores y las madres avanzamos ahora
todas esas circunstancias y estamos con
el pueblo estamos con la gente que sufre
injusticias mientras haya injusticias
estaremos en la calle
ahora a lo largo de todos estos 45 años
no era pasaron por los más diversos
contextos políticos sociales culturales
como fueron cambiando las respuestas a
su lucha a lo largo de todos estos
tiempos
y la respuesta fueron esté cambiando
porque las circunstancias y el país
también que deseo
las madres igual de cualquier manera
estamos
actualizadas y no estamos solas ahora no
estamos solos estamos rodeadas de tres
generaciones que nos acompañan y que
están en la misma lucha
la madre aprendimos a luchar por lo
mismo que luchaban nuestros hijos e
hijas nosotros somos herederos de esa
generación de los 70 somos es en vez de
ser los hijos los herederos somos las
madres las herederas de esos hijos e
hijas creen de esto que plantean ahora
ahora hay madres de desaparecidos a lo
largo de toda américa latina
lamentablemente también en otras
regiones del mundo países como méjico
colombia son tan sólo algunos de los que
sufren este drama no mujeres a lo largo
de todos estos países que han perdido a
sus hijos por la violencia
y hay países donde están recién
comenzando estos caminos estos
recorridos de lucha qué mensaje tiene
usted en ahora para estas madres que
están iniciando esta lucha
yo les digo que no hay que bajar los
brazos y hay que tomar esa herencia que
nos dejaron este que tenemos que dar el
ejemplo que se puede luchar sin
violencia como hemos hecho nosotros y
como se hace hasta ahora estamos
vinculadas a las madres de toda américa
latina estamos vinculadas con madres
hasta de asia y de hasta de áfrica
tenemos este tenemos vinculación a
través de spe de fans y de estas
organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
estamos vinculadas en todo el mundo este
por eso seguimos y decimos no hay que
bajar los brazos hay que seguir luchando
hasta el final de nuestra vida donde hay
una injusticia tenemos que estar tenemos
que acompañar a la gente que sufre
porque tenemos ese mandato que nos
dejaron nuestros hijos y nuestras pistas
vinculado a ese mandato que le dejaron
sus hijos e hijas no era usted ha dicho
que por el argentino vive en resistencia
y que hay que alimentar ese sentimiento
con el mayor amor posible podría
desarrollar esta idea tan interesante
sí como no yo pienso y pensamos las
madres y a través del amor te puedes
seguir y se puede tener fuerzas para
rebatir todos los inconvenientes que
fuimos subiendo teniendo en estos años
tuvimos este muy rechazadas este muy
abandonadas por la iglesia católica
argentina que fue partícipe de lo que
fue el terrorismo estado la iglesia esa
que es mayoritaria en argentina fue
participe con todos sus hombres salvo
excepciones de esta represión brutal que
tuvimos así que ahora nosotras seguimos
y seguimos de la mano ahí estamos todas
las madres crecidas de demás más de 90
años y seguimos sin claudicar y yo le
decimos a la madre del mundo que con el
amor se va este paliando el dolor con el
amor transforma a la lucha en
en ese amor que podemos dar todavía que
todavía nos quedan
algunos de espacios pocos nos quedan
pero pero todavía estamos en esta
carrera de tener éxito en la lucha como
decía el che hasta la victoria siempre y
nosotras decimos hasta la victoria
siempre venceremos
decimos todavía decimos en la plaza la
coordina muchísimas gracias ha sido un
placer su presencia en france 24 en
español
igualmente les doy un abrazo muy grande
y esperamos que nos vamos a ver acá en
argentina o en el país que sea nos
veremos para abrazarnos nora ha sido un
gusto y un placer se lo reitero una vez
más a nuestra audiencia le invitamos a
que sigan informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com sigan con nosotros
[Música]